[Music]
i would say that there's hope that no
matter how dark your situation is or how
overwhelmed you feel there's always a
way the listener watching the show
remember this we're with you it's not us
versus you it's us with you and that's
what we specialize here at ramsey
solution is a clear path
there are steps that you can take and
you can get unstuck so stuck is a choice
and it all comes down to
choosing
to change i always want listeners to
come away with a plan that they can
execute which gives them hope i want you
to laugh i want you to have hope all of
that but i also just want you to learn
because that's why we're here is to help
the caller that we are talking to but
also all the listeners the millions of
people out there and so if you can take
tidbits of information apply it to your
life and it changes the outcome
of where you are financially
that would make me really happy when
people watch or listen to the show what
i hope they walk away with is a little
bit of confidence that they can take
that right next step with money no more
excuses ignorance was bliss until they
got the advice from us and they went i
know too much i know what i got to do
now my hope for them is that they walk
away with clarity realizing that there
is a clear path from where they are to
where they want to go and that they now
have confidence to actually take the
steps necessary to have transforming
actions in their life to get them where
they want to go when someone watches the
show i hope they walk away with hope
knowing that no matter what they're
going through or how overwhelmed i feel
that there's always a way to get through
it if you are willing to push through
for a season and focus you can find a
way through any situation somebody sat
there and listened to what i'm going
through what i'm experiencing and yeah
they poked fun at me yeah they we all
laughed together yes we cried together
but they showed up and they listened
and nobody else in my life listens to me
but they did
that's what i hope they come away with
so the impact of this stuff dave over 30
years you're we're now seeing the fruits
of that generationally i mean you meet
you know what we call financial peace
babies which is the kids of parents who
went through financial peace who have
done this plan now they're growing up in
this culture you meet baby steps
millionaires who follow the baby steps
and go oh my gosh dave i'm a millionaire
did you find that starting to trend over
the last few years
yeah we had to be real careful to name
them financial peace babies too some guy
got on there and he goes i'm a dave
ramsey baby and i'm going no you ain't
if i'm like no you're not either
change that phrasing sir yeah we're
going to call you a financial peace baby
oh yeah okay i get it
yeah whoo
ramsay baby no you're not a ramsey baby
no no you're not
promising from this point forward i'm
going to refer to everybody's ramsey
baby
just just be known that that's not okay
okay
yeah but it's that's the thing i didn't
see that if we did it long enough we
would see
the third generation now
starting to move
and uh because some of them are you know
they get it in high school in the hot
weather high school curriculum or
whatever and
you know we'll see that uh with the work
that uh that we're doing in the career
area we'll see that with the work we're
doing in the mental health areas too
yeah um i mean it won't take but about
10 years and you'll start to see
the generational
effect of it um
but you know and it's odd that we used
to say it was kind of a tagline but it
was the truth change your family tree
change your family tree and if you learn
how to do relationships you change your
family tree if you learn how to get into
a career that is satisfying you more is
caught than taught rachel says so the
kids are watching they're gonna
go oh wait a minute maybe i can make
more money not less
and do something i love and not have to
be in a toxic environment wow i don't
have to go i'll make less so that i'm
happy that's that's a bunch of garbage
so we have we can break all that
put that truth out there and break that
the mythology off of them and then
another generation comes along yeah and
uh we're all here you know carrying the
torch and in 2021 there was a very
intentional shift from the dave ramsey
show to the ramsey show and it's slight
we just took out four letters but it
means a whole lot more what is the
future of the show to you
well that was a part uh that was the
uh
one of the last major steps
of moving the brand off of a single
person to many
you know we added all the personalities
over the years and
we had intended to
start putting personalities more on the
air with me
in
21 then covet happened
and so we went okay we have to as a
group get on the air and talk to people
in john's case be able to calm them down
and his trauma
background you know people were
traumatized and so you know
facts are your friends you can't
function in fear critical thinking
skills break down frontal lobes shut
down all that we went through all that
stuff and and so bringing john and
everybody else into that and going
i get that you're scared we're all a
little scared this is an uncertain time
but here's what it's not here's what
it's not calm down get your thing and so
we accelerated that and got everybody on
the air during that time and then
by the time we had been doing it almost
a year
with everybody on the air as co-hosts
permanent co-hosts permanent co-hosts
we said all right it's time to go ahead
and just make the change in the name
itself we didn't make a big deal out of
it and so so did no one else it was
great well it's expanded even beyond the
ramsay show now with the ramsey network
so we've got a whole network of shows
with the ken coleman show and the rachel
cruz show the dr john baloney show the
fine print and it's amazing how it
really is like succession we're looking
at it right now as we start to enter
these different areas and and help so
many more people there's a lot more
people to reach out there and uh job
security the world is still in shambles
so there's plenty of work
for all of us so that's the good news
and the bad news but as we wrap here
what would you guys say to the person
regardless of their situation it's money
it's career it's life relationships they
feel stuck right now and they don't see
a way out what do you just wish you
could say to every person
i would say that there's hope that no
matter how dark your situation is or how
overwhelmed you feel there's always a
way there's always a way
i i would say that uh that stuck as a
choice
uh i i'm not in any way minimizing the
the feeling of being stuck or the
circumstances where someone feels is
that because i take it quite literally
you know i remember i would tell someone
to to put themselves for a moment when
they feel stuck financially
uh emotionally uh professionally oh i
can't get out no one's gonna give me a
shot whatever and i'd say all right uh
first we're not gonna panic you know
we're gonna go okay there is a way
christina said so beautifully there's a
way and that's what we specialize here
at ramsey solutions a clear path there
are steps that you can take and you can
get unstuck so stuck is a choice so once
you move into this all right there is a
way i got to find the way and then when
i find the way so that's clarity now i
know i can walk the way and i can begin
to shift from i feel hopeless
and helpless and i go to
i am confident
that if i do the little things and
struggle as we were talking about
earlier embrace the struggle i can get
unstuck and i think that that's it's the
mindset to realize that if you think
you're stuck it's because you've chosen
uh to believe that you are hopeless and
helpless and you're not yeah it starts
with that paradigm shift where you gotta
go i gotta think about this differently
before i can even believe it's possible
and take action and once you think about
it differently go i'm not going to stay
this way where i am right now is not
where i have to be a year from now six
months from now 10 years from now when
you have that vision for your life
you've got that powerful why
man it'll light you up and so that's
what i want for everyone watching yeah i
would say
look for
options and look for people because i
think when you're stuck and there is
hopelessness it feels like there's
there's no options or if there is it's
just one and that one option is terrible
it's the only thing i can only do this i
can only do that whether it's you know
with relationships or you know money or
just like it's just that and i'm like
there's always options
so even when someone calls on the show
and they're like yeah i've got i have to
do this i'm like no you don't think
about abcde i mean there are options out
there so i would say just stop look for
options and then look for people because
i think when you are
um actually our past we're talking about
this one when you're discouraged it can
be a very lonely place and you and you
draw in and you talk about this a lot
but i was like get people around you and
whether that was people are us and you
tune in and listen to the show
um
but really encouraging you yeah people
in your life that can walk with you that
can hear you
uh that can actually maybe bring you
options of things that you you aren't
thinking about because when you are
stuck
it's like a tuttle vision so have
find those options and find those people
to walk with you yeah yeah it's i echo
that i think
the the longer i'm doing these shows the
less relevant my quote-unquote all the
articles i've read are
it's the fact that i'm a guy that
they're slowly starting to trust this
guy who loves me and he'll be honest
with me and they'll lay out this long
three or four minute problem
and it's like
it's just this
and they go oh
and i have to remember that in my life
that when i get stuck when i see a big
problem i need to
stop like you just mentioned i gotta
stop and i gotta reach out to somebody i
gotta make sure somebody sees me and
then that's gonna be my path out and so
i've gotta
the listener watching this show remember
this we're with you it's not us versus
you it's us with you and the more we can
create an environment where people feel
with us and that we feel we are able to
sit with them i think that um these
shows will continue to do well um no
hope deferred
makes the heart sick
and i've been there
most people have been there
where you feel stuck or you feel
panicked or you feel
trapped in a certain
one decisions all i can do or have two
possible decisions both of them are bad
two options and you've we've all been
there that
that hopelessness is
so
debilitating
the rest of that verse says but
[Music]
and that's a big word
when desire comes
it is the tree of life
so when you end your hopelessness
when you in your moment
connect with people
find a plan
[Music]
know what the next step is
fog starts to
clear and
you say desire
now desire has come
i am choosing
to use that word that you used earlier
agency i'm choosing to
what john would call take locus of
control i'm choosing to say i can
control the controllables i'm choosing
to say yeah this is a bad deal
but
it's not forever
and it all comes down to
choosing
to change
when desire comes
it is the tree of life
and that's the only person we can't help
on this show is the one that won't
choose desire
instead they they want to become
defensive
and they want to intellectually build a
set of walls around their life
emotionally build a set of walls around
their life that say see i can't win i'm
a victim i it's impossible for me to win
i'm stuck someone else is going to have
to fix this i can't fix it
um and we can't help that person
until we can get them some desire throw
them some desire over that wall and get
in there and then they start to knock
down the victim walls and they start
moving from victim to victor
well dave speaking of choosing i'm
speaking on behalf of the group and
millions more thank you for choosing
many decades ago to step into the
spotlight to give people hope and money
and now all areas of life grateful for
you all honored to do this incredible
work with you and make an impact thanks
for being here